watch last week's episode you'll get it
star wars the last Jedi is days away and
we're continuing this week with our
second countdown on the controversial
prequels as I stated last week there are
a lot of things I don't like about the
prequels most of my complaints aren't
new as these films have been subject to
heavy criticism since they were released
but like I mentioned I do have a small
attachment to these movies I grew up
with them since I was 10 years old and
they were everywhere the excitement
surrounding the release of episode one
is still something I remember pretty
well
toys collectible Pepsi and mountain dew
cans and birthday party Darth Maul
lightsaber fights are all things that I
can still vividly recall I like the
movies less and less as time went on but
there were some parts that positively
stuck with me a few glimmers of light
and the dark boy what were they and how
did these moments stick out in an
encouraging way let's find out these are
the top 5 best Star Wars prequel moments
from a certain point of view number 5
showing off the full power of the Future
Empire here was kind of epic from
episode to Attack of the Clones the
Grand Army of the Republic has finally
been confirmed as thousands of clone
soldiers militarized in front of
Palpatine and a few others showcasing
just how much authority he now has in
his secret conquest of the galaxy
what tied this all together was the
Imperial March being played while the
prequels in general were subpar John
Williams music continued to be one of
the things we could latch onto as never
dropping in quality hearing this theme
blare as the future stormtroopers
mobilized was a really strong moment
I do have to mention that having all the
clone trooper costumes be completely
computer-generated was a ridiculous
distracting and wasteful misstep in this
scene however it was obviously a
necessity and didn't take away from the
moment it's one of only a few such
moments that interested me in an
otherwise pretty awful film number 4
qui-gon always spoke very highly on you
I wish you were still alive I could use
his help right now
qui-gon jinn would never join you I
always thought you and McGregor's
obi-wan was the most tolerable part of
the prequels and when they put him in a
scene with Christopher Lee's Count Dooku
and actually turned out to be a pretty
good exchange from episode 2 attack of
the clones obi-wan has been captured on
Geonosis while trying to track down
Jango Fett and is joined by Count Dooku
a leader in the separatist council it's
revealed here that Dooku was qui-gon
jinns master in the Jedi arts as he
tries to recruit obi-wan to his cause
there's actual tangible tension in the
scene concerning the memory of qui-gon
and the true intentions of the Galactic
Senate I think it's by far the best
moment in the movie and one of the best
in the prequel trilogy I would have
loved to have gotten more of this type
of character depth throughout the movies
we see obi-wan get upset at the
suggestion his master would have joined
the perceived bad guys at that point we
know Dooku was sort of trying to play
him but he did bring up some good points
which quality villains do what if I told
you that the Republic was now under the
control of a Dark Lord of the Sith no
that's not possible
the Jedi would be aware of the time the
dark side of the force has clouded their
vision my friend what would Quan have
done in this situation we know from
episode 1 he was kind of a rogue from
the council and didn't always play by
their rules if he knew the information
Duke who told obi-wan about a Sith
controlling the Senate how would he have
handled it would he have joined Dooku to
fight this perceived evil or would he
have seen through his former masters
trickery and form a third option it's a
great question to ask and a scene that
features some good acting from two
decently strong characters in these
three films that I mentioned I like Ewan
McGregor's obi-wan
number three you and the chosen one
and we say that you the stylist is not
join them
bring balance to the force not leaving a
dock this was supposed to be the most
emotional moment in the prequels and at
the very least we can feel the pain in
Obi Wan's in from episode 3 Revenge of
the Sith Anakin and obi-wan have just
finished their historically significant
battle which leaves Skywalker maimed and
full of hate obi-wan lets his emotions
go as he berates Anakin for his betrayal
instead of anger sadness is the most
prominent feeling here we can see it
written all over his face and a great
performance by McGregor that only does
he feel sadness for his friend and all
the pain he's caused
but obi-wan blames himself for failing
to stop Anakin's fall to the dark side
while it's hard to feel bad for Anakin I
always sympathized with Obi Wan's
position
he just had to pretty much kill his best
friend a person he's raised since he was
a young boy this was the deepest of
betrayals and that's all reflected in
Obi Wan's words my father Anakin
I love to with Anakin finally off the
deep-end
Hayden Christensen got to let loose all
the hate that have been building in his
character since the previous movie it's
a very raw performance and one that is
passable in comparison to McGregor's
this legendary moment in Star Wars
history was brought together well by the
acting I like this scene even more when
it's spliced together with Alec Guinness
his explanation to Luke in a new hope
good going Ewan number two
real homeless I think we all can agree
that Darth Maul was one of the coolest
villains in Star Wars period from
Episode one The Phantom Menace the
climax of the movie begins with the good
guys trying to take back Naboo and in
doing so they're confronted by Darth
Sidious as apprentice Darth Maul qui-gon
jinn and obi-wan Kenobi engage Maul in
battle which leads to one of the best
lightsaber fights in the whole series
and ends with a death that had long
lasting implications more points have to
go to John Williams once again duel of
the fates is the prequel signature theme
and it's a great one it's introduced
here and really drives the action of
this climax with an energy that was
seldom seen in the three movies
the reveal of mall says it all with no
words needed it's a shame that
everything before this was so dull this
climax seemed like it was from another
movie with how thrilling it was the
battle rages on to quaggans death and
obi wan's quick vengeance it sucks at
the killed mall so early in the trilogy
but at least he lived on in the Clone
Wars and rebels animated series this
woman was close but another just topped
it
and the number one best Star Wars
prequel moment is Darth Plagueis was a
Dark Lord of the Sith so powerful and so
wise
he could use the Force to influence the
midi-chlorians to create life this is a
legitimately really good scene from
Episode three Revenge of the Sith
Palpatine is talking to Anakin at an
operatic performance that is indicative
of some of the things he's speaking of
he meticulously jumps from topic to
topic digging into Anakin's mistrust of
the Jedi Council and his insecurities
about Padme looming death the ladder is
under the guise of his story about Darth
Plagueis the wise and how he learned the
power to stop people from dying many
things are suggested here including
Anakin's conception and some a
Palpatine's background this is in line
with Obi Wan's talked with Count Dooku
in Episode two the feeling is similar
but this is darker and more sinister
because we know that Palpatine is
getting to Anakin it's in McDormand and
his creepy manipulative best he is
fantastic here dark side of the force is
a pathway to many abilities some
consider to be unnatural a suggestion
that Palpatine or Plagueis created
Anakin is an interesting one I'm not at
all a fan of the midi-chlorians stuff
but at least it is used in a clever way
here the story of Darth Plagueis gives
us a small peek at what Palpatine's
origins were as he was likely the
apprentice that killed his master ironic
you could save others from death but not
himself this is just a really strong
scene featuring a great performance and
in my opinion it's the best moment of
the prequel trilogy over on my personal
channel I've been reviewing season four
of Star Wars rebels and we'll have a
review up of the last Jedi as soon as
possible so check it out for more Star
Wars content I want to hear what you
guys think what is your favorite Star
Wars prequel moment what do you want me
to cover next on the show leave a
comment and let me know to keep in touch
like my facebook page facebook.com slash
awesome walter b or follow along on
twitter to take part in more polls about
what may be covered in the future come
back next week
for a brand-new episode of top 5
you